Ciao Gu ciao ospite, nonostante il tema sia
quello delle figure di m***a, ne ricordo una che
pensandoci ora è stato semplicemente un
momento passato con il mio primo
fidanzatino. Ricordo che eravamo a casa sua
spaparanzati sul letto ma improvvisamente la mia pancia
comincia a fare rumori sospetti,
in poche parole dovevo sganciare aria
Cercai di trattenermi ma il destino
volle che lui completamente a caso
cominciasse a farmi il solletico, e in quel
caso è stato difficile frenare
l'aria che il mio corpo voleva buttare fuori. E' inutile dire che faccio
scusate la volgarità per favore, una
delle scorregge più forti che abbia mai fatto. Volevo
sotterrarmi, la parte carina però è che
ad un certo punto lui smette di ridere
mi guarda e dice "Sai che ti dico?",
e nulla, ne sgancia una più forte della mia
Devo dire una cosa, ha una bellissima voce lei. Sentissi il c**o!
Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Vita Buttata, il tema della
puntata di oggi è "Figure di m***a"
Però non si può dire..."Figure di cacca"
Anzi no..."Figure di feci"
"Feci figure"
Per una puntata così speciale ho deciso di
invitare qui all'interno degli studios
di casa mia una persona che appena passa
davanti a te ha proprio quell'olezzo di m***a
No una persona con la quale veramente
potermi divertire, con la quale poter
veramente ridere delle disgrazie altrui
più che con chiunque altro
La mia consecutio temporum oggi non è presente. "Abbiamo l'ospite di avere l'ospite, grande piacere
ospite". Mio fratello Enrico.
Eccoci qua. Enrico sei pronto ad ascoltare le
figure di m***a delle persone? Le feci figure? Le feci figure delle persone? Vai! Sei pronto? Prontissimo!
Così partiamo a caldo, ormai sei un
professionista di questo format. Eh caspita!
Tu stai dormendo in piedi. Ho dormito tre ore...Stanotte? Si
Quindi stai morendo.
Sono uscita con dei miei amici e siamo
andati diciamo in una simil discoteca,
c'erano le drag che intrattenevano, un
sacco di alcol, un sacco di persone
che ballavano...una discoteca...a un certo punto io
avendo alzato abbastanza il gomito,
mi hanno raccontato che le drag mi hanno
invitato a salire sul palco e mi hanno
eletto Miss Z*****a 2015. Che bello!
Ma scusa quando uno alza
il gomito in realtà lo alza anche quando
sta in autobus comunque
Ma sai da dove viene il detto di "alzare il gomito?"...Che alzi il gomito. Ah bravo lo sai
Ma qualche medico, ma perché tossisce sempre? Ma perché penso ho preso freddo
A Natale certo. No sono guarito e
poi mi sono riammalato. Quand'è che sei
guarito? C'è stato un periodo dove ero
guarito ma uno si ammala quando sta bene
Se sto sempre male, nel senso...non so come
spiegare il concetto. Uno si ammala quando sta bene. Ma se tu stai sempre male? Non ti puoi ammalare se
sei ammalato, sei già
ammmalato...e io infatti quello che sto dicendo è stai
sempre male. Ero guarito...Ma sei distorto tu? Che vuol dire? Che saggezza!
Ma un'ora fa non ce l'aveva (Lavinia)
Nonono un'ora fa era guarito
Ciao Gu e ciao ospite,
allora a parte il fatto che ho un
abbonamento speciale alle figure di m***a, la
peggiore e più dolorosa che mi è
capitata è stata qualche anno fa quando
al termine di una partita, io gioco a
calcio tra parentesi, andiamo sotto la
curva, sai ci teniamo per mano, mi sono
ritrovata in ospedale con una spalla
lussata...Allora non so se mi sono portata
sfiga ieri a raccontarti di questo mio
infortunio ma sappi che ieri sera mi
sono anche rotta il legamento crociato e il ginocchio. Evvai sono una persona anche fortunata!
Ma questa qui gioisce delle sue sventure, cioè col ginocchio in fronte. Smettila di gioire, perché ti fai
male quando gioisci. Domani te ne invia un altro...Basta Enrì sti germi!
Poi lo possono...che schifo! Ciao Gu e ciao ospite, oggi vi volevo raccontare di quella volta che
in palestra stavo male e praticamente
dovevo buttare una scoreggia. Ho detto "Vabbè lo
faccio mentre corro perché tutti fanno
rumore, non si sentirà". Bene abbiamo
cominciato un esercizio, quindi abbiamo
cominciato a correre però saltellando
e così decisi di farlo in quel momento
Il problema è che ogni saltello ne usciva uno a
pressione
e quindi anziché essere silenziosa si entiva tutto
alché tutti si fermarono e si sono
girati a guardarmi. Feci finta di niente
sono caduto a terra buttandone uno ancora più rumoroso e dire che volevo morire dalla vergogna
Era tipo una papera di gomma. Io mi immagino "Pra pra pra". "Hey che stai facendo? Pro. Non sono io! Prò prò"
E' capitato anche a me. Cioè? Tipo che ne
so, durante gli allenamenti
a me ad altri, fortunatamente eravamo
tutti maschi, quindi "Prem prem"...Un porcile!"
Però succede. Io invece, io sono spesso in
treno Roma Milano, Milano Roma, Napoli e
compagnia bella. No Napoli ci vado in macchina, quindi mi posso liberare. Tutti quanti pensano che io in treno
sia una specie di vecchietta perché mi metto la
mia giacca sempre sulle gambe
La realtà è che se uno a volte alzasse quella giacca morirebbe. E' diventata double face la tua giacca. Sisisi
Dentro è corrosa. Hai un accendino? Io non posso avere un accendino, esplode il treno
Io sarei morto di imbara...
Figure di germi.
Praticamente all'epoca si portava
molto i giochi sopra al computer,
giocavamo in cooperativa io e questo mio cugino
Ci chiamavamo ogni tanto per
parlare la, per fare le cose diciamo
coordinate no? Questo mio cugino che mi
chiama tante tante tante volte
volte al giorno e mi chiama sul telefono di casa. Vidi il numero "Che palle!", risposi
"C***o vuoi m***a? Antonio sono Olga la mamma di Salvatore
mi passi a ma? Io panico "Si certo subito".
Che figura di m***a! Quella volta. L'unica volta in cui
lui ha voluto è stato punito.
Anch'io sono stato punito. Cioè che ti è
successo? Stavo al bar, si avvicina un
ragazzo e mi fa "Posso farti una domanda?"
E io "Sì sono io", e lui "Non so chi sei,
ma l'apple watch come ti ci trovi ?"
Non è vero! L'unica volta in cui mi si sono
avvicinati per chiedermi un qualcosa che
non fosse legata al canale. Io volevo
morire! Ancora Valentina me lo ricorda
perché era lì davanti a me, è scoppiata
a ridere. E te credo, c'ha ragione, e quell'altro basito
Io umiliato. "Ma chi è questo?"
E che gli hai detto almeno sull'apple watch? Cioè sembravo uno della apple
Certo! "Io e mia sorella abbiamo 13 anni di
differenza, lei aveva sei anni quindi io 19
mia sorella la racconta sempre e si vanta,
in quei momenti voi solo sprofondare"
Ciao Gu, ti racconto di quando...Non fa ridere! Invece fa ridere! Io ho una sorella più piccola di 13 anni
l'accompagnavo a imparare ad andare in bicicletta. Ah io non so andare in bicicletta ma portavo lei a fare i giri
Ci siamo perse per i vari cortili e vialetti
del condominio e la bambina di sei
anni mi ha riportata a casa...non è divertente...oscurami la voce se puoi perché questa cosa è già imbarazzante
di suo. Perché ti sei vergognata del risultato
Ah se vuoi un'altra vicenda divertente Gu, ti dico solo che dalle ecografie
la mamma del mio ragazzo mi dice sempre
che lui doveva nascere femmina. Questo discorso un
giorno è uscito a tavola davanti a tutti i parenti pugliesi, un'enorme
tavolata e lo zio, sai quello non divertente
di turno che è a tavola, davanti a tutti
decide bene di chiedermi se visto che dall'ecografia questo pisello non si
vedeva, se adesso fosse cresciuto. Oscurami la voce perché sennò lui mi uccide, è qui
davanti mi sta rincorrendo. Ma è
cresciuto?...Mandaci l'ecografia
Mandaci le foto di adesso. Ma quindi quanti hanni c'ha mo questo bambino?
Questo bambino è quello "Non è
divertente, non fa ridere". No ma è cresciuto
E' rimasto un'ecografia. Svegliati! Torna nel presente. Enrico svegliati! Okok, io pensavo che
avesse un figlio. Jo quiero de ablar con mi, con mi familia, con Enrigue
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video. Come sempre...Che è?
Ma hai scoraggiato? No. E' la sedia (Gianmarco)
Ma che vuoi? Enrico! Non ho scureggiato. Pfff. Nessuno può sapere se sto mentendo. Esatto
Siamo arrivati alla fine di questo video ragazzi...Pff Guglielmo!
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questo...
Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di questo
video, fatemi sapere qua sotto dei co...scusate non
so parlare, nei commenti quali sono state
delle figure di m***a, ma proprio....strong. Strong!
Cioè quelle lì proprio che non vuoi svegliarti il giorno dopo. Mi sono dimenticato come ho iniziato la frase
Punto a capo. Grazie Enrico per aver fatto questo video. Pffff
Grazie a te Guglielmo...Come sempre vi
chiedo di iscrivervi, di mettere un
pollice in su. Un gomito...e di mettere un gomito in su e soprattutto attivare qua sotto la campanellina in
modo da non perdervi i prossimi episodi.
Noi comunque ci vediamo la prossima
settimana sempre con un altro
video alle? 14. Ben detto
Ciao
Ma i "ciao" io li devo dire. Ho deciso...non
posso salutare? Vuoi dire un'ultima cosa?
Si allora. Allora ciao